We can factor this numerator as the difference of two squares. We can write it
as 6 minus x times 6 plus x. For this denominator we want to find the factors of
negative 48 that sum to positive 2. These factors are negative 6 and positive 8.
When I look at my factors it doesn't seem as if anything can simplify out to
equal 1 but if i look at these two factors i can see that these are opposite
polynomials. The constant term 6 is positive while this one's negative and the x
term is negative here while this x term is positive. This means I'll have a
factor of negative 1. We can see this if we were to just switch the order of the
terms for these two, we'll have negative 6 plus x, then I can factor a negative
1 from this factor. I'll have negative 1 times positive 6 minus x. I change the
signs of both of these terms since i factored a negative 1 out. These factors of
6 minus X simplified to 1 but i still have a negative 1 out in front, just like
I thought here. Whenever you see opposite polynomial factors you can simplify
them to be negative 1. We don't need to show all this work. So we're left with
this expression. Now, I want to acknowledge there are a lot of different answers
here. This negative sign could have been distributed to either the numerator or
the denominator. If we distribute the negative 1 to the numerator, we could have
gotten this expression. Or switch the order of these terms and you got this
expression. These are all equal. If we distribute this negative one instead of
the denominator, we can wind up with any of these expressions. And in fact, all
of these are correct. In general, it's easiest to list the negative sign out in
front of a fraction and then write your rational expressions.